Mối cán bộ đảng viên trước hết là người đứng đầu
nếu hương quan hành động của thẻ,
kết quả thức chất thức sự là những người chuyên cảm hứng
có dậy khách hỏng công viễn trong mối tập thẻ điệu phương,
mối cơ quan, đưa viện.
Mối người dân Việt Nam không ngừng buôn lên từ chủ, từ lực tự gần,
đóng có tích cửa sự phát triển của đất nước.
Mối định hình tiến tiến tiến,
biểu biểu trong họ tập làm thương quá,
cần không ngừng lăng tỏa mạnh mẽ những giá chị đã tạo dực.
Tiếp tục công kiến, nóng có nhiều hình nữa trong hành trình.
Huyện thật khác phọng của bác hồ kiến yêu.
Pát vui chuyển thống ngình nằm dựng nước của sự nước,
với sự mạnh đại đòn kết tỏng rất tập,
hát phọng vô lên không ngừng,
giữa những xác xoài đường của tự tưởng hồ chim mình,
sự lánh đạo xong xuất tài tình của đảng,
chúng ta nhé đỉnh sẽ viết tiếp,
những chiều mới dựng dựa trong hành trình phát triển,
vô lên mạnh mẽ,
xây dự thành công nước Việt Nam được lập,
tự gần hành phục,
phần vinh, phần mình thì work có vý thêm và tin ngoái quan trọng trong cọng đồng của tế.